and you want to leave it like that or do
is there one song you want to play from
the new record that maybe you feel is
the best song on the record or something
that speaks to people is there anything
it feels weird leaving it on this night
because it's quite dark but I guess the
record is is that but this is the song
that I wrote about
um the feeling of grief and it being
feeling like your youth had been taken
away from you like the it's and with all
of my friends who had lost people in
their teenage years like I feel
fortunate that I'm in my 30s and this
has happened to me and you kind of look
at your mates who'd lost parents at like
12 or 6 or 14 and you go wow like that's
when you became an adult and that's when
you had to deal with with this stuff so
this is a song called um end of Youth
which I think is yeah one of my
favorites on the record
[Music]
I've been depressed since you left tried
to fill the hole with wine stop the
drugs when she came clean my act up
overnight if you reach with no reply
I'll see you when I see you man you
can't told me through the fall if we
don't know if I can land try to grow but
the past it tears me down to size tell
the world how to process but don't take
the same advice I remember what I say
then the mornings filled with fear can't
get a handle on my grief when every
memory turns to tears it's been a long
year and we're not even halfway there is
this the ending of our
when pain starts taking over
I just don't know if I can never Just
Let It Go
everything's fooling apart When Love is
Real there's never closure
I guess it's no part of life but I can't
help but feel alone
we spend our youth with arms and hearts
to wide open
and then the dark it's in and that's the
end of Youth
I've been lost since the teens but
pretend it's all alright all my UPS led
to false I let the trainer in my life
just a boy at the start they lent on
like a man you were meant to be my
friend and not to take all that you can
disengage to create try to reinvent the
wheel no one knows what they want so I
just give you what I feel if I slip and
get high I know the low is always near
when I'm down I never see you when I'm
up you all appear it's been a long year
and we're not even halfway there it's
the
is this a youth when pain starts taking
over I
don't know if I can never just let it go
everything's falling apart When Love is
Real there's never closure
I guess it's no part of life but I can't
help but be alone
we spend our youth with arms and hearts
a wide open
and then the dark it's in and that's the
end of you
oh
[Music]
it's been a long year and we're not even
halfway there is this the ending of our
youth when pain starts taking over
just don't know if I can never just let
it go
everything's falling apart When Love is
Real there's never closure I guess it's
no part of life but I can't help but
feel alone
we spend our youth with arms and hearts
to wide open
and then the dark gets in and that's the
end of you
we spend our youth with arms and hearts
to wide open
and then the dark it's in and that's the
end of Youth